[Music]
No all right
I don't know podcast laws of gaming
dotnet play NYC who is this fine
gentleman in the room today
I'm Andrew Lindy from juncture media how
are you doing doing fantastic and saw
the night we had our eye on this game
right here so tell us about how do you
pronounce it a vari oh yeah you got it
Varia versus oru first year a varriya is
the name of the planet okay
and this is our PvP game so it's called
the Varia versus yes so I'm getting
Final Fantasy vibes right now yeah all
right
so the first thing I want to ask you off
top is that on I'm noticing that style
you said PvP so there are two modes like
break this whole thing down so a Varia
versus is a PvP game only but we are
also working on a story game we wanted
to start with which what we thought was
new to the genre was you know final
fantasy PvP which is what we made here
so you can play online you can play
local you can play vs bots there's
sixteen heroes bots yeah you can make
over 2000 different parties so it's like
totally customizable and once you learn
this battle system and the characters
we're gonna come out with a story game
called Avari it goes to be immortal so
once everybody's like a pro at the
battle system we're gonna throw a bunch
of story challenges at you in a separate
game wow it sounds pretty cool one thing
that I noticed is like you don't really
see a battle game in this vein sort of
the Final Fantasy without it being
resembling like an RTS like a Starcraft
or something like that
so way to do guys come up with this idea
to sort of have it like this turn-based
thing but not grid based and then how
how do you balance that status
that's gotta be difficult it was a big
challenge but I mean we set off like I
grew up always wondering why can't I
take my Final Fantasy 7 party and battle
against my friend like a dick is loving
this right yeah like that's what I
wanted to do and I can never could I'm
like we both have memory cards yeah we
like stick them in and like just fight
so they don't so we made that and so you
know when you play vs. BOTS there's no
timer but when you're ever you're
playing against the human there's a
timer going so you got to act fast we
call it ultra fast turn-based combat and
I think that's really what it feels like
you're gonna your hands will get sweaty
so now you say time or like how fast are
we talking that human decisions have to
be made before the next action so we
based the timer on this fact when you
hit level 5 with a hero by the way the
leveling system is like a MOBA you level
inside of the battle and you can level
up to level 9 and get your ultimate
ability at level 5 we made the timer
based upon how long it takes to do 3
ultimate abilities and 3 mini games
because you get a mini game that's like
random when you when you trigger your
alt to boost the effectiveness of it so
you can fairly pull off three characters
in 3 alts with the timer that's what
it's based on wait around like 25
seconds you said to also you there's a
minigame in between that so it's not
like you're just pulling moves off and
they're affected by it and then they go
so that's great because it gives you
even more like minut control of the
battle as opposed to like I swipe do
whatever you dodged it or anything like
that
that's amazing man because you would
think a lot of that stuff turns into
kind of an auto battle or you attack
them with something then their turn
comes that's awesome well we just wanted
like I always imagine the scenario where
eventually people are gonna be like oh
this is the best party right so what if
you have two people playing the exact
same party all the time we needed that
thing to make the difference so there's
dexterity elements that come in for
example if you have two parties are the
same all the characters are the same
speed stat right so who's gonna go first
whoever acts faster with that character
okay so if I have a dice or and you have
a dice or if I input faster mine's gonna
go first hit you maybe kill you before
you even get to act so there's all these
things layered in there that make it you
know not just like an auto
like I said let me ask you this question
as far as characters two questions one
as far as the amount of characters
that's electable and in the second one
thing Final Fantasy is kind of known for
us like these summons and these conative
do we have like these kind of big kind
of like on boombastic kind of powers
kind of thing those are the ultimate
abilities which are called focus burns
okay so they don't summon like a summon
but they they're the biggest moves in
the game everybody every character has
two different ones so there's sixteen
heroes and each hero has two archetypes
that you can load them out in so it's
almost like there's thirty six yeah it's
almost like an additional characters
yeah so there's over two thousand party
combinations you can make so instead of
customizing at the character level you
customize that the team comp level you
know so like that's kind of what you're
thinking is you know I need like a DPS
guy I need like a utility guy and a
healer or maybe you could kind of go all
DPS and just hope that you can kill them
before they get a chance to get their
defenses up is each archetype completely
different in terms of loadout in terms
of top of the tree the skill tree
expands so basically what the archetype
changes is the build path of the
abilities plus the ultimate in the item
so the ultimate in the item are
completely different but the three main
abilities are the same except they build
completely different so in one archetype
you might build two like really strong
single target damage the other one it
might build out to a party attack like
you know area-of-effect so it really
changes how you're gonna play when you
switch the archetype yeah that's really
cool man so currently right now we are
we currently out on Steam right now
we out the store baby the store right
there awesome and so on again
out on Steve now muscle aware Lords a
lot of console guys here is there a
chance at any point this make comments a
console there's a chance but right now
you can see we're playing on controllers
so I mean you load it up on Steam we
talked we made this game for controller
I'm a console guy too but it's my first
game and I was like consoles are way
bigger you know frugal process I didn't
want to get in over my head but we
designed it with controller in mind of
course you can play it with mouse and
keyboard - oh that's also man got my eye
on it man and if one thing about so
being that this is just a vs. portion of
it are you including like lore and stuff
in it to sort of get people invested in
the characters yeah because you said
this is an act is a full-on RPG coming
afterwards so another one here let's try
it so chaos so he's got solved the
puzzle flip them all green with before
the time runs out and he can boost it oh
this one this one tricks people wha
oh yeah yeah they got busted
yeah the thing is with the meaning game
you get the base effect just for
triggering it but if you complete the
minigame you get a boost a big mole okay
there we go
all right there we go and we got again
online but that is there Tom I was going
to say that it's not like couch co-op
battle oh wow so we got BOTS we got
local split-screen we got online okay
that's awesome you can always you can
always place one way or another
we have a pretty active discord discord
GG / of Aria so that's gonna be for both
games but right now there's still only
one that's out you know so right now
again multiplayer components out and as
far as how long down the window before
we get that maybe that single-player
story cinematic kinda experience I'd
love to be able to put a demo out there
in the next 12 months that's like the
goal but you know nothing like announce
tomorrow so we're still working we're
still lurking we have a really good demo
right now I'm just putting some final
tweaks on it you know talking to some
publishers trying to get it lined up now
you already have first man of warriors
looking good so what you think what I
love is that this shows like this give
devs the opportunity to do something
different we have not seen this type of
battler that's not an RTS you don't see
that so amazing work amazing very
looking forward to immense absolute
presence already here first man of
always check it out y'all Lords the game
and got the eye on it
[Music]
you
[Music]